bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france rappelez-nous ce qu'il ya lancé
il y a dix ans le mouvement des indignés
bonsoir merci pour votre invitation
basse qui a démarré on va dire le
mouvement des indignados en espagne
c'est une sorte de ras-le-bol général et
surtout c'est une situation de crise
économique et sociale profonde en 2011
après le début de cette crise économique
non seulement espagnol mais mondiale en
2008 2009 ce qui a provoqué que beaucoup
de jeunes quittaient déjà
structurellement dans une situation de
précarité affronte la situation
économique et sociale et le marché du
travail avec encore plus de difficultés
la phr la crise économique avait frappé
très durement l'espagne avec une montée
très rapide du chômage de grosses
difficultés des réformes inévitable à
faire y compris sous le gouvernement
socialiste de zapatero et beaucoup de
revendications des jeunes qui voyait se
fermer de plus en plus leur avenir sans
plus tard qu'est ce qu'elle reste de
cette contestation portée par les
indignés alors c'est intéressant parce
que
il ya eu la création du fameux partis
politiques podemos avec son leader
pablo iglesias mais qui a fait en
quelque sorte un peu long feu c'est à
dire ils se sont absolument présenter
comme les héritiers de ce mouvement
spontané ce mouvement de rue ce
mouvement essentiellement composé de
jeunes et c'est un parti qui a été créée
les dires de toutes pièces par coop bolo
iglesias et ses amis universitaires qui
a eu un succès un premier succès aux
élections européennes de 2014 en se
revendiquant de ce mouvement des
indignés et en annonçant que c'était le
parti politique qui allait faire la
transition entre le mouvement de rue et
les réformes sociales
le problème c'est que beaucoup des
revendications qui avait été présenté
par le mouvement spontané des indignados
beaucoup de ces revendications
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout satisfait
notamment la question des frais de
scolarité des frais universitaires qui
pour les jeunes et sont très importants
en espagne beaucoup plus qu'en france ou
dans la plupart des pays européens
sondés feraient extrêmement élevé et par
exemple cette revendication là n'a pas
été satisfaites
aux dernières élections régionales à
madrid le seul candidat qui proposait
une réduction voire une gratuité de
certains frais universitaires c'était le
candidat socialiste gabilondo et pas du
tout par exemple le parti podemos qui
est resté sur des revendications
sociales parfois un peu maximaliste
c'est à dire on veut avoir tour et tout
de suite si dans la nature de ce genre
de mouvements qui sont les mouvements
plutôt radicaux de revendications et
total et on s'aperçoit que aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il reste de ce mouvement là
la traduction politique qu'a voulu faire
podemos de ce mouvement de contestation
de protestation dans les institutions
ce drôle de représentation en fait a
vite tourné court parce que aujourd'hui
beaucoup de ces indignados où beaucoup
même des militants du parti podemos
contestent la politique du parti podemos
il ya eu énormément de divisions au sein
même du mouvement podemos qui est devenu
finalement un mouvement minoritaire qui
a cru un moment dépassé le parti
socialiste espagnol mais qui est retombé
à un niveau plus conforme j'allais dire
à la réalité de sa capacité de
représentation c'est d'ailleurs autour
de 10 11% des électeurs espagnols ce qui
est beaucoup moins impressionnant que
les 25% que parfois ici est de
revendiquer les responsables de podemos
et notamment son leader pablo iglesias
alors comment est ce que vous expliquer
cet essoufflement de la formation
politique podemos est ce que cela
correspond à une forme de contestation
espagnole qui est retombé ces dernières
années non je pense pas que ce soit une
forme je pense que c'est une forme de
désillusion
c'est une forme de désillusion le site
très difficile de toute façon de 2
de traduire un mouvement de rue dans un
mouvement politique durable sur le long
terme les mouvement des indignados
qu'est ce qu'il refuse qu'ils demandent
et finalement il demandait en réalité
tout simplement la satisfaction de
revendications qui sont des satisfaction
des revendications de jeunes sur
beaucoup de questions et quand on veut
faire tout en même temps où et quand
l'un podemos promettait tout en même
temps
promettez de bouleverser la vie
politique promettez des réformes
sociales économiques et même politiques
même institutionnels dans tous les sens
c'est l'un des partis qui réclament avec
beaucoup d'insistance un référendum sur
le maintien ou pas de la monarchie
constitutionnelle en espagne c'est un
parti qui ouvertement républicain c'est
pas le seul mais c'est un parti qui par
exemple sur cette question-là a voulu en
faire une question prioritaire ce qui
est pas la question institutionnelle à
mon avis la plus urgente c'est une
question qui mérite débat mais qui n'est
pas la plus urgente est lorsque le parti
podemos commence à être représentés dans
les institutions
d'abord dans les mairies ne faut pas
oublier que c'est un parti qui a eu
beaucoup de succès dans les élections
européennes de 2014 et qui ensuite a
investi beaucoup de conseils municipaux
en espagne des gouvernements régionaux
également mais qui finalement a échoué
en fait à traduire dans des mesures
rapides et concrètes
cette revendication de ces
revendications générales que afficher le
parti politique podemos dans ses
campagnes électorales donc il ya une
escorte de il ya une sorte de d'écart
entre les promesses et les réalisations
concrètes
une fois qu'on arrive aux institutions
le deuxième le deuxième spécificité on
va dire de du rôle de poe demos dans les
institutions c'est que na ne dépend ça
ne dépassant pas la majorité absolue et
de loin de là on est obligé de faire des
pactes c'est comme ça
donc dans les institutions dans les
gouvernements régionaux locaux il faut
il faut conclure des pactes notamment
avec la gauche et peut demos a eu
énormément de mal à accepter cette
culture du mac qui pourtant existe en
espagne qui qui qui s'est pratiqué très
longtemps avec notamment le parti
socialiste espagnol mais c'est podemos
avec son côté un peu maximaliste radical
a longtemps refusé de jouer le règles
des règles du jeu démocratique qui
consiste à créer des gouvernements
coalition et a cédé un peu lorsqu'on
n'est pas majoritaire il faut savoir
aussi si des pour obtenir quelque chose
et ça c'est quelque chose que les
dirigeants de peau des mots sont dans
beaucoup de mal à accepter l'acceptent
désormais dans le gouvernement de gauche
de pedro sanchez au niveau de l'état
espagnol
mais parfois ça a été très difficile ça
a été très compliqué d'ailleurs
d'arriver à ce gouvernement de coalition
au niveau de l'espagne d'un montrait
très rapidement parce que le temps nous
manque malheureusement est ce que vous
direz que bien que podemos pèse beaucoup
moins lourd aujourd'hui dans le champ
politique espagnole est ce que vous
direz que il a toutefois été il a
toutefois inspiré les courants
politiques espagnols plus
traditionnelles établies contraint
finalement de de prendre note de cette
de ce mouvement populaire est ce que
plus largement c'est ce mouvement
espagnol qui a inspiré des mouvements
comme les jeunes et jolies en france
d'un mot s'il vous plaît je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il était le seul la seule source
d'inspiration au niveau de l'espagne
bien sûr l'apparition de podemos et d'un
autre parti aussi qui décide à dano ce
qui est en train de disparaître maman a
forcément bousculer les partis
politiques traditionnels
il a surtout remis en cause le
bipartisme traditionnelle qu'on voyait
au niveau de toutes les institutions
espagnoles
il a remis en beauce - non non mon avis
c est ce que véritablement sai t on peut
en faire un bilan globalement positive
je ne suis pas sûr parce qu'il y à
beaucoup a critiqué aussi dans
l'attitude de certains dirigeants de
poney moss est cette attitude un peu
parfois extrêmes et radicales qui
facilite pas justement les accords les
grands accords entre différents partis
parfois il faut accepter de mettre un
peu d'eau dans son vin de céder sur
certaines choses pour obtenir des
résultats concrets et que je crois que
la tradition politique de podemos est
encore trop récente pour peut-être
comprendre cette nécessité qui est la
réalité politique dont non seulement en
espagne mais dans tous les pays
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation ces raretés france josé rojas
alonso juriste on sert secrétaire
général du parti socialiste ouvrier
espagnol de paris